today we see how to install a very
popular continuous integration tool
called Jenkins on windows first we see
how to install Java development kit jdk
is one of the prerequisites you need in
order to run Jenkins then we'll set up
the jdk path in the environment variable
after that we'll see how to download and
install Jenkins on Windows once that's
complete
we'll run Jenkins on localhost:8080
which is the default port for running
Jenkins then we'll have a glance at the
Jenkins server interface and look at
some of features present on Jenkins
finally we learn how to build and run a
job in Jenkins to download and install
JDK simply type install JDK on Google
and click on the first link which is
Java s8 development to get aid as you
can see we get a list of downloads for
JDK since I'm on windows 64-bit system I
have already installed JDK version for
Windows 64 before you install JDK you
also need to accept the license
agreement let me show you where my jdk
has been installed first I go to my C
Drive Program Files under the Java
folder you find two more folders that's
JDK and JRE now let's set up the path in
the environment variable go to system
properties under the Advanced tab select
environment variables under system
variables there are two more variables
called Java home and JRE who Java home
contains the path for JDK I'll show you
where it is go to JDK folder copy the
path and paste it in the value section
JRE home contains the path for GRE
similarly go to the GRE folder copy the
path and paste it in the corresponding
value one more thing you need to is
setup the bin folder location for JDK in
path variables let's see where the bin
folder location is
here it is after setting up the location
click OK to finish the setup now shall
we check if Java has been successfully
installed for that go to the command
prompt and type Java - version you can
see our Java is successfully installed
and it's up and running
the version we've installed is shown
here now let's download Jenkins on
windows simply type download Jenkins on
Google and click on the first link here
we can see my Jenkins provides two types
of releases long-term support release
and weekly release as I'm interested in
the most stable release so I will go for
LTS now when I scroll down I'll get an
option for Windows once I select that a
stable installer starts to download you
can see it says thank you for
downloading windows stable installer so
now our Jenkins has start downloading
this might take a few seconds
delenn-- maybe you can catch up if
you're left behind
okay so the download is complete now
let's go ahead and unzip downloaded
Jenkins fire
after the unzipping has been done we
start the installation click on this
folder click run next this is the
default path where Jenkins will be
installed we don't need to change it so
we can just go out the next install
after this the Jenkins installation is
successfully completed select finish yes
that's all
now that installation is complete let's
go and explore Jenkins go to your web
browser and search localhost colon 8080
0 you can see that it says welcome to
Jenkins so I have already created the
username and password for Jenkins I'll
enter my credentials and that's all this
is how the Jenkins homepage and
interface looks like and that's all
signing in yes so that's the dashboard
and this is how the Jenkins homepage and
interface looks like so if you're
installing Jenkins for the very first
time it will ask you to install some
recommended plugins I have already
installed mine so I don't need to
install them once again now there are a
lot of things you can do in Jenkins let
me run you through a few of them there's
jobs that have already created and run
this is new item it allows you to create
a new project so you can create a
freestyle project a mavin project a
builds pipeline etc then going back to
the dashboard there is built history so
this section shows you the status of
your build here you can see what's the
builds name the time since the build is
running and what's the status of your
built there is another very important
section called manage Jenkins
here you can configure your system you
can configure global security
credentials then there's some global
tool configuration you can also download
and manage your plugins here you can see
there four tabs where you have some
updates you have some available plugins
you have the plugins that you've already
installed and then there is advanced
plugin as well now let me show you how
to create and run a job in Jenkins so
coming back to the dashboard let me
select new item we can name our job here
let me name the job as Jenkins demo I
will create a freestyle project so
select that and click OK
this might take a few seconds so when we
have created that here we have a number
of options that we can go ahead with you
have a source code management building
triggers building environment and then
of course some postman actions
so that's about creating and running a
job in Jenkins let's give some
description to our job so we have
created the job we give description
something like this is my first chenkin
job so we will not use any source code
management tool in the build section as
you can see there is an option to
execute Windows batch command
click on that and here you can give you
command let's use the echo command I
would write something like hello this is
my first Jenkins demo and then I'll also
give the date and time parameters so
that I can track on what date and time
this job was built
that's it so click apply and then save
okay so this job is created now let's
build it go to bills now once you click
it you can see a build history has been
created click on that
in the console output you can see the
output of your very first Jenkins job
it says hello this is my first Jenkins
demo what you gave the command box you
can see that and you can also see the
day date and time when this job was
created so we've successfully created
our first Jenkins job so thank you guys
today we saw how to download and install
Jenkins we had look at the Jenkins
interface and the things you can do
using Jenkins finally we created our
first Jenkins job and ran it
successfully so that's all from my side
today for more such interesting videos
subscribe to our channel simply learn to
get the latest updates thank you and
happy learning hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here